einsam ist es ist das grinsen sie lachen
über das geräusch einer machete die
einen menschlichen körper zerfetzt
gs kämpfer im nordirak nach dem töten
feiern sie und verhöhnen ihre opfer oslo
anders breivik vor gericht
nach jedem treffer auf eines seiner 69
opfer hat er die jubeln
ss männer kämpfer für den islamischen
staat kindersoldaten die verliebten
täter aus paris massenmörder wie breivik
und andere eine ganze schar von mördern
hat der kulturwissenschaftler klaus
theweleit eine analyse unterzogen und
ein psychogramm der tötungs lust
entworfen der ausschlüsse für dieses
buch war briggs lachend ja lachen beim
töten wie die überlebenden das berichten
die mädchen die ins wasser gesprungen
sind und hören wir auf der insel
die dagebliebenen umlegt und dabei wie
die eine schreib jubelt wie ein
torschrei anders breivik will mit seinem
töten in die geschichte eingehen ein
fanal setzen gegen die feministisch
marxistische gesellschaft norwegens er
es formuliert über 1500 seiten an
rechtfertigung hat er aufgeschrieben
material das klaus theweleit untersucht
hat um seinem lachen auf den grund zu
gehen
vor gericht lacht er weiter vor gericht
lacht er die richterin aus erlach die
psychiater aus und sagte na klar ich
weiß aber was ihr sagt ich bin verrückt
ich bin zufrieden und lacht und lächelt
auch als die angehörigen der getöteten
kommen weiter nimmt dass sie die
verhandlungen kaum aushalten können weil
sie dauernd in dieses grinsen die
gesicht gucken müssen und er sagt was
einzige was mir leid tut dass es nur 67
oder 69 waren es hätten viel mehr sein
soll
es ist ein triumphierendes lachen das
arrogante grinsen des mörders dass klaus
theweleit in den gesichtern und seelen
der killer verortet den prototypen
verkörpert henry fonda in sergio leones
spiel mir das lied vom tod
dieses lachen kommt aus einer anderen
welt es ist ein lachen in der gewissheit
im auftrag zu morden im sinne eines
höheren gedankens einer ideologie einer
religion
sie sind immer heile im sinne der
höheren ideologie sie verstecken sich
dahinter und heißt immer ihr könnt uns
nicht ab urteilen nicht eure gerichte
sind für uns nicht zuständig unsere
höhere ideologie genau so redet die ss
steht darüber kein staatlich
bürgerliches gericht reicht in unsere
ferien und damit leben sie sehr gut und
das ist auch die grundlage dafür dass
sie lachen können
beim chillen klaus theweleit hat sie
schon in seinem kultbuch
männerphantasien mit den ursachen von
gewalt mit dem entstehen von
faschistischen bewusstsein beschäftigt
mit dem beschädigten männlichen körper
den beschädigten menschen die später zu
nazi tätern wurden der film das weiße
band von michael haneke öffnet den blick
in diese rigide welt vor dem ersten
weltkrieg
sie kommen alle aus geprügelten
generation sind durch elterliche oder
andere gewalt militärgewalt drei schulen
et cetera und jugend bünde oder diese
misshandlungen auch durch durch kalte
mütter wie ich das in männerfantasien
beschreibt die sogenannten reisen mütter
die kinder schreien auch wenn sie nass
sind werden allein gelassen stundenlang
hunger et cetera
all diese zu richtungen des körpers die
passieren in verschiedenen kulturen
verschieden aber insofern gleicht dass
sie eine bestimmte sorte zerstörten
körper hinterlassen
und diese zerstörten körper morden tiefe
leid sucht die ursachen dafür in den
psychischen und gesellschaftlichen
bedingungen gewalterfahrung schwache
väter mangelnde anerkennung gestörte
beziehungen zum anderen geschlecht
diese verletzungen wollen die täter
überwinden indem sie macht erlangen
sie alle haben primär dieses bedürfnis
mehr oder weniger zerstörter ich sage
fragmentierter körper sich das realen zu
bemächtigen und dazu gehört die eigenen
körper eine machtposition zu bringen und
das kriegen sie nur hindurch gewalt
durch töten töten im namen allahs oder
einer übergeordneten rasse klaus
theweleit sieht die ursache für das
zwanghafte muss nicht in den ideologien
jeder dieser killer kann sich auf irgend
so eine übergeordnete ideologie berufen
und das heißt sie fallen damit als
erklärung dafür weg wenn es die eine wie
die andere wie auch die dritte wie auch
die vierte sein kann in der namen
getötet wird dann sind die austauschbar
denn nicht der grund für das töten
anderswo bereits botschaft wir sollten
weniger die systeme verantwortlich
machen in deren namen gemordet wird
es ist nicht der islam nicht das
christentum nicht die ideologie es sind
die menschen die töten
und dann lachen